y'all were enemies right now let me tell
you we're here
yeah i ain't gonna say we was enemies
yeah but i know what they i got to watch
them and
yeah and vice versa right if you guys
can come together though i mean it's
like who couldn't come together oh yeah
you know what i mean all of this is for
the growth you know and you got to
recognize it
[Music]
to me i just said to somebody i'm saying
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you guys this is
this is one of the happiest days i i've
had in like 10 years i'm not like
sitting seeing you two in the same room
that's funny on the same couch i can't
tell you how much it it it means to me
man yeah it's like god have a way of
doing
his way
right way all the time that's right and
i believe that this is the right way you
know the two of you are two of the the
wisest and and and strongest and uh most
level-headed men that i have in my life
i've i've learned from from both of you
guys i look at both of you guys as uh
real gifts
in my life and and profits from my life
like i i look at the way you guys have
lived your life the way you've conducted
your life the way you are
uh the way you're you you're regarded by
the people around you and uh you have no
idea like the amount of gratitude and i
i just i hold you guys sacred so it's uh
it's incredible incredible for me to
just have you guys together and it's
just something i've i've wanted to see
for a real long time well i mean i think
it's awesome you're telling the story
too you know i think it's a story like
when i met you years ago it was a story
need to be told yeah and i really think
it does and i mean everything happens
for a reason you know like i we talked
about before i you know i don't make it
don't make it personal i'll never make
it personal you know it's a business
right you know and that's i can sit down
with goat i sit down hell up hug bam bam
you know i mean
[Music]
back in the day you never would have
thought that yeah you know we all get
old and we chill out we were talking
about the funniest time you know when uh
one of the guys was buying dope from you
know went to go buy dope from goat and
he thought he knew him because his twin
identical twin brother had stopped going
on the interstate he was a dps trooper
and he said i know you know you're the
guy stopped me on there he goes that
wasn't me and i was like he was telling
the truth but were identical twins and
it was a funny and that was stuck in my
head
more than anything that i remember that
was the funniest thing in the world you
know for the guy to be sitting there
that ain't mean
and he was telling the truth
but it was they were identical twins i
said man you tell your brother quit
[ __ ] with people
you can't do this business
and they all are identical twins but man
i said i appreciate you know being able
to tell the story and uh if it helps
somebody i think that's the greatest
thing
and trying to do something different in
our city i would say that needs
something positive
going on you know
and i know a lot of negative stuff went
on back in the days but sometimes you
know negativity bring positive you know
people just got to look at it that way
you know
and and some people could look at and
say well okay they did this this way
well i ain't gonna do that this way i'm
gonna do it my way and they may be
better than the way i was doing it you
know what i mean
and so sometimes you just have to
you know be grateful you know i'm more
grateful than anything that
i'm in this position because i'm gonna
tell you i never thought i would be in
no position like this you know
i mean when i went to prison i ain't
never think i was going to come home and
somebody was going to be talking about
doing a story about my life you know
and uh it's amazing man then when you
change your life and give your life to
god and start praying and praying and
and be sincere you hope it's real about
other peoples you know to see that hey
man this man is serious about what he's
saying and he's doing it he ain't just
talking about it but he he talking the
talk but he walking the walker
you know as he go
and i hope
whatever come on this movie or the
series or whatever it be i hope it lifts
up somebody else in this city you know i
hope it's something to look young guys
and look at and say you know what
go change his whole life why can't i
change my life you know
and uh if like i tell i tell little
young guys when they work with me
and uh i drive trucks and sometimes uh
they may send some of the little guys
over there from the temp service
and then they'll ride with me that day
and i don't i don't i don't bring god to
them i let them come to me with so once
they open up a door then that's when i
be straightforward with them you know
and i let them know look at man
i've been down that road
i know what it's like you know
ducking and dodging the police and
worrying about if you're gonna have to
kill somebody today or if you're gonna
get killed today because somebody's
gonna try you you know especially in my
position the position i was in
a lot of them didn't know but i was in a
strong position man where if my friend
them bam and all of them i knew if
anything come about me they was going to
be wrecked out you know no matter what
you know
and don and i don't know i knew i had
people that's gonna be racked up my
cousins my nephews and cut them guys
were gonna be hey man that's my uncle
that's my cousin no hell no you know
but
that ain't the life you want to live you
know what i mean that ain't the life
that ain't it you know and when i
realized that
going to prison was the best thing that
could have ever happened to me
it changed me a great deal you know
and first when i first went i was like
man i'ma kill them dudes man for
testifying on me
but when i got in jail and i started
going to church and i started listening
to my
son's grandmother
and she's always say baby pray sometimes
pray twice a day
and i start doing that and that's when i
learned how to forgive and by me
learning how to forgive that learned me
to okay then
maybe that was the best thing that could
have ever happened to you to go to jail
you know so
my goal was when i came home to get me a
job
and start me a little lawn service i
came home i started buying lawn
equipment then i messed where i got me
the truck that i i'm working to i said
okay this is right here you know i
prayed and i asked god for this and he
gave me this
i don't want to look back the other way
no more
and that's how i've been living my life
the 10 years i've been home
you know so to sit here and talk to mr
townsend
[Laughter]
but like i told him i said but i told
thompson to up that's it but just think
about it you ain't never stop me for
nothing
he never stopped me for anything when i
was on the street
he'll come in the bottom
but i'd be laid back i'd be i can't wait
i look at him and i see him but i don't
say nothing to him i don't open my mouth
cause i know i'm dirty i know i'm doing
dirt so i ain't really trying to start
nothing with them you know what i mean
my thing was
as long as the police come down there
and like bam say do your job right
you know when the police was looking for
me and they came down there and they
arrested me i ain't i didn't clown with
them i know you know they were looking
for me so i went on to jail
it's simple as that you know but
to live at life
i just wish these kids open up their
eyes to something better you know
education
uh start go to a trade school
or just do something different in your
life
killing everybody you see look at you
ain't the answer
because eventually somebody's gonna kill
you you ain't gonna keep on killing
people then getting away with it it just
don't happen like that in life
it don't happen like that
guys i see guys kill dudes
and
two or three months later they did
you know what i mean come on man wake up
god god god send a message to us every
day he wakes up every day that's that's
the best blessing you can ask for
so that's why i just changed my life and
and i feel so happy to be who i'm at
right now i ain't rich
but i ain't po no money
[Laughter]
you know what i mean yeah so you know
for you to come in my life john i i've
been teasing some guys i said you just
got to know people that have places
and so you know i laugh and joke with
them and then but to be serious i try to
school the young guys that come in my
area and when they open up to me then i
i explain to them you know and i let him
know i don't care what you do man it's
the consequences for everything you do
when you doing dirt when you're doing
something that you know is not law it's
a consequence behind it and you just
don't have to suffer if you get caught
up you know
so that's that's that's how i live my
life now you know oh man right on when
was the last time you all saw each other
do you do you
court
yeah
yeah yeah at trial yeah yep that was the
last thing god that's been how many
years ago was it oh nine to four nine to
five yeah
yep i was just a youngster yeah i wasn't
too young
[Laughter]
i just realized how old i am now
thinking about it i'm like [ __ ]
yeah what a long time that's when you
that's basically when the sentencing was
was 95. yeah well we went to trial at 95
and we got sevens in nine to five 95
okay okay it was a it was the largest it
was the most defendants they ever had in
the trial like that 12 you know the 12
defendants and everybody had a couple
attorneys they had stadium seats they
built they built rafters right yeah i
mean it wasn't crazy you know i mean it
was like stadium see different roads and
stuff like that
yeah for the whole trial and everything
like during that case did you think
there was any chance that you were
getting out of it oh i know i wasn't
going i know i wasn't going
but you got to play the game
even though
the beyond excuse me for catching up
even though they never caught me with
drugs i never ever got caught with drugs
i never ever sold drugs to no undercover
law and the in the only law they got up
on the witness stand and said that no he
didn't he he i come to him and asked him
no he said i ran to him but the dude was
lying the whole time you know he was
just straight up line all the guys that
got up on the witness stand against me
lied except for one of them
the one sean chung was the only one told
the truth
i i don't lie he did tell the truth i
was giving him dope you know what i mean
i was but the rest of them that got up
there all alone was lying you felt
fairly sure that those guys were that
they were going away huh i mean yeah you
don't
take somebody to trial unless you're
pretty sure that you know you got a
decent case and everything like that dan
burke was one of the attorneys for that
was big don's at times
and i'll never forget he had the
funniest thing he had a picture of a
mountain and he had a picture of a
molehill and his opening state was
they're trying to turn this and then i
thought man i've got to write that down
i said that is the funniest thing i've
ever seen in court you know
and you god rest him he's dead now but
uh it was it was pretty funny when dan
did that you know yeah i mean i said hey
i've never been to court that many
people in my life and to usually two
defensive attorneys each you know but
you know i never it reminds me of you
know if you've ever seen the wiley
coyote cartoon with the wiley coyote and
the sheepdog and they clock in and you
know they're best friends they live
together the sheepdog and the coyote and
they live together well they go to work
they clock in and their enemies and as
soon as they clock out they go back home
living with each other i said you know
what it's like it's kind of like a
business you know except you don't take
it personal then you know just you know
job doing a job and everything and i
love my job and i love being retired
that's the life being retired i'm the
poster child for retirement i'm telling
you seeing goat here today and and and
seeing you know what what he's talking
about now and he he's a man who's
changed you know like how does that make
you feel i think it's awesome and you
know and i've seen and goat can tell you
too you get people get the jailhouse
religion and you know and you've seen
that many times but they would go to
church you know on sundays and they'd
come out fighting you know the next day
and so or they as soon as they hit the
street they lose that religion but you
know and man it's he's got it i mean you
can tell i mean this guy's a god-feared
man you know and i respect that like
crazy you know
you know i'm a god-fearing man too and
uh
he kept his religion and i love that you
know like i said you've seen it you've
seen guys come in they go we call it
jailhouse religion
and they get it because it makes them
look good it's great for you know the
parole board and everything oh he goes
he's in church every time that's opened
up you know and i started out working in
a prison you know with the sheriff
that's what you had to do
the cdc back in the day with cci
and uh you know i saw that you would see
it but this guy i mean you can tell i
mean it changed his life and that's i've
told him i said i've said bunch of
people come up to me you know that i put
in prison before and shake my hand say
man you saved my life you know but you
know just like thompson was saying you
got a lot of guys being in prison and
then they'll get off into the bible and
i mean when you talk to him in prison
and you'll be like man this dude is he
know you know this bible good
but once they walk out that door
then the bible just be tossed to the
side and i'm gonna tell you when i was
in i used to go to church in jail but i
never said that once i got home i was
just gonna go to church i said i'm gonna
go to church and then i'm gonna um thank
god for for letting me out of that
prison and that was it but when i went
to church and i realized you know what i
got to be here every sunday
because this here is the only thing
going to
make me be a better person you know
going to keep me away from foolishness
and
and and
clowning with anybody about anything you
know and so that's why
i just embraced it more and more and
more and then some of the older guys in
church and the older women's in church
who've been in church all day life they
helping me along the way you know what i
mean by encouragement and and just
looking at me and saying we appreciate
how you be in church every sunday and
this and that and when we ask you to do
something you so polite you so you know
what i mean and all of that stuff
together make you a better person you
know
and uh
and like i tell i tell don and bam them
and i tell them i don't care what y'all
do with child life i love what i would
do with mine
you know just like when i was in the
streets i know i was in the streets i
know i was in the streets ain't no if
whatever industry i'm a part of it one
way or the other you know but that ain't
where i ever want to be again then i'm
getting out of age now what i'm gonna do
being in the street i can't run for the
police
look at that who can i run but we get
away from you know what i mean
early 63. okay you got five years old me
i'm 58 yeah
so get slower don't you yeah yeah for
real
is this at all i mean for for either of
y'all is it is this hard for you guys no
no this is not at all simple yeah
but like i mean don't you think i mean
like right now like in this cut like
y'all were enemies right i wouldn't tell
you we're in it
yeah i ain't gonna say we was enemies
yeah but i know what they i got to watch
them
yeah and vice versa right and vice versa
and i guess what i'm saying is like if
you guys if you guys can come together
though i mean it's like can't like who
couldn't come together oh yeah you know
what i mean but like don't you think
that the fact that you are both i mean
the one opposite teams look you're on
opposite teams but both of you guys are
like i know both of you very well you're
both extraordinarily confident with who
you are like like both of you guys
whenever i had some the common answer i
gave her oh yeah man i'm good with that
like you're unshakable both of you guys
have had to fight for your life both of
you guys have been in very dangerous
situations both of you guys have have
seen all kinds of you've seen i think
probably the worst that this world can
kind of show you guys have both suffered
you know unbelievable tragedies in your
life but you come back you both have joy
you both live life to the fullest you
both have beautiful families that you
love with all your hearts you both stand
up and respected by everybody who knows
you all of this is part of growth you
know and you got to recognize it you
know
and i recognize it through god you know
what i see
he doing for me and my family you know i
got a good wife i don't have to have a
second thought about her you know what i
mean she said i'm gonna go do that she
ain't got to worry about me well yeah
dude
she ain't got to worry about it okay
i'll holler at you later you know
and that's how we operate how important
is that you got a wonderful wife too
like how like wha what has that been for
you oh my gosh man she's like
settled me a lot really has settled me a
ton peace of mind big time big time
she's you know beautiful bright you know
i mean she's a very confident woman and
she's always been there for me yeah and
so and i'll always be there for her i
mean i i know it's a probably
cheesy ass question but to
for everything you live what what would
you say what would you say is the secret
to happiness in this world
god
god is the secret to happiness and i
mean you can't never go wrong with it i
don't care what you do you can't never
go wrong with god
when you with god
that's happiness in itself
and that's that's my secret to happiness
and i ain't playing that's my secret you
know when i go to a sick if i get in a
situation now
and i just pray about it and i just ask
god to remove that problem away from me
and then i put it in this hand and now
i'm gone on by my business and i tell my
i tell my daughter this is what makes me
my wife no man with me because they
this is what what gift gets to them they
say you don't care about nothing
i said if they don't care about nothing
it's just that i don't worry about a
little bitty stuff i don't let little
stuff get next to me i i mean both of
you guys have really have that in common
you're a real happy guy man you know you
have peace of mind what do you think
what's your secret man you know i worked
hard i had a great job and like i told
you i love retirement uh and i'm with
goat you know god
guitars guns and family that's yeah you
know i mean you know i have i help
people you know i told you i do the
guitar for vets thing you know i teach
the
vets with ptsd guitar lessons and you
know it helps them give them peace of
mind as long as i can get out there and
help somebody that
that's always me and uh there's like
almost 200 chapters throughout the
united states that's awesome yeah and i
started one here a while back that's
beautiful yeah i love it i love doing it
and what what what frustrates you right
now like what are you worried about
these days you know what
i don't really get frustrated it's hard
to frustrate me now you know
because you didn't sing so much you know
did so much until you know how to
maneuver waif around a lot of
foolishness you know what i mean uh i i
put it like this one day i was up on the
corner
and my cousin
and he was arguing with another little
dude
right
and the little dude was his with what
was when our cousin's brother
and when they got rid of all you know
what i did when got in my truck and left
you know what i mean because i don't
want to be i don't want to hear it i
don't want to see it so whatever y'all
got going on i don't want to be a
nowhere around i got in my truck and i
leave
it's easy to walk away
some stuff you see when you see it's
going to be so foolish just go about
your business and how about you are you
worried about anything these days are
you
no you know i mean i'll always be the
the person that i am you know i'll
interject if some something's getting
out of hand you know and things like i
mean that's always my mentality is to
you know go in there and help somebody
and i feel like you know if anybody
needs help then i'm i'm always there to
do something like that you know
yeah i'm different you know i mean man i
was a freaking crazy go-getting working
sun [ __ ] alcohol but not like a
workaholic and i'm now
and uh i mean i wouldn't go home i work
so much and man i have just you know
relaxed so much since i you know got off
the job left that left that world yeah
yeah and everybody said they told me
there's no way you'll retire they said
you can't retire they said there's no
way they said man you'd love this [ __ ]
and
i was in florida the next you know the
next day after i retired and man i just
loved it just stay busy you know i got
so many you know hobbies in the mall
hell i'm busier now that i retired than
i was when i was working i think yeah i
don't know i ever had time to work
you know you're retired you got a pickup
truck and you got some friends there you
go you've got some friends
trust me
can you come over here and do this yeah
right
yeah well again y'all i mean i just uh
it's a real special day for me i'm i'm
i'm gonna let y'all you know go about
your night i'm i'm just uh it just it
means the world to see you all together
you guys got anything you want to say to
each other or
well we talked upstairs it was kind of
fun we said man i hadn't seen him in so
long you know and we even talked about a
couple people we knew from jail and
stuff like that you know
and uh i mean i'm so glad that he turned
his life around because you know
the sad thing is you don't see people
like him that often that will turn their
life around you know that will go get
out and they go back into it you know i
mean we rested hell i rested not only
you know i was in it so long arrested
people arrested their kids grandkids you
know i'd said they'd always say oh no
you you know mr townley you know you
know my dad or you know i said oh how's
he doing he's good you know but i'd end
up arresting them
no
but it's good to see him it's good to
see him you know change you know and
everything like that yeah yeah man yeah
let me ask just one more thing just in
terms of like you know you hear about
like the war on drugs right like y'all
y'all
you know like in whatever that was in
the the 80s and the 90s and what that
was and the toll it took on this this
this this country and it's still kind of
playing out with all the people in
prison
you know that that spent so much time in
prison i mean how many were you did 17
yeah 17 years you know you know all the
all the people that that died all the
the law enforcement uh that got killed
in the line of duty all the people on
the streets that got killed what is your
guys take on that you know mine was
always you know if i could help somebody
if i could save somebody's life by you
know
either putting them in jail or you know
and that's many times i'd catch people
you know and and they wouldn't go to
jail you know it depends on what you
know kind of conversation we had and
stuff like that as long as i could
always help somebody i felt like i was
making a difference and people would
always say you know you're never going
to win the war on drugs i said but you
know it's like a big snowball rolling
down here if you don't chip at it and
keep chipping out of the way it's just
going to get bigger and bigger and you
know i always felt like i made a
difference especially when i had people
come up and tell me i saved their life
you know by putting them in jail and i
lost a lot of friends you know that were
killed in line of duty and stuff like
that i've been there you know seen it
and
you know it just it tore you up to see
that kind of thing you know
for you know just unnecessary stuff
and what about you
well you know like i was telling you the
other day
when
when uh
the police is nowadays is not like the
police back then
that's it that's a different generation
of polices
back then
if i
got in tour with the police
and i walk away from him and he see i'm
i'm running from him he ain't finished
shoot you in your back
what they'll do is say i get it i'll get
him later okay he's going to be ready in
this bottom i'll catch him later and
that's how they would do
but the cd police is days killing these
guys shooting them in their back when
they running away from them i just think
that's a power move for a police officer
you don't have to do that i remember
back in the days when i was a little boy
and and i see the older guy run from the
police you know what they'll do shoot up
in the air
they'll shoot and give them a one to
stop and say stop and nine percent at a
time they stop
they got they wanted shot you know what
i mean but these police now and dudes
too it ain't just all the it ain't all
about the police dude just
is is uh
putting themselves in a position to get
killed too you know
and
i think when the person got a gun on him
and it's it's i think it's scared of
police nine days you know what i mean
back then we could have a gun on us and
the police would stop us and take the
gun right out for us we will never reach
for our gun
but they'll shoot you now if you just
got a gun on you that's crazy the way it
is today and back then i would have been
shot because i ran from a mana police
officer i mean i stayed running from
here
i always running from we could be
gambling and stuff and we see the foley
relate them they jump out the car we
jumping and running you know they
weren't shooting in your back like that
back then you know i got a question what
do you think about the way the bottoms
looks now it's totally oh you ever
thought you'd see apartment complexes i
mean i've never imagined all right
apartments
in the red cross for my church and right
there by the movie studios yeah you ever
think you see a movie studio never never
never yeah never i was so shocked but
you know life brings about a change you
know i mean
i'm glad it changed because like i say
when i left the streets a lot of the
girls down there wasn't working they
wasn't doing that for themselves because
we was making sure they had everything
you know what i mean now they working
and they taking care of themselves real
good and i'm proud of them more than
anything you know
i think the only thing that's the same
down there is the livingston and the
hospitality house
lucky liquor yeah lucky liquor yeah look
yeah but they're gonna probably end up
selling that they're gonna probably end
up taking that down yeah that's what's
gonna happen
i mean what would like when you were
growing up in queensborough what did you
what like when you were a kid
what was the bottoms to you
oh what did you think about it we always
knew about i mean you know we we're
about the same age and everything like
that i mean and you know that has a big
long history the bottom you know they
were back in the day they used to run
cattle from down there to the red river
you know back on the streets were brick
and stuff like that with dirt and then
it became brick down there and we always
knew about the history but i lived in
queensborough queensborough was my world
you know i mean i was a kid i ran the
street to queensborough
you know that was just a different
neighborhood for us
i appreciate you all and i love both of
you guys we appreciate you getting
together and everything yeah it's really
cool i don't know if anyone realizes how
cool it is but it's really cool man i'm
i'm really you know i'm just touching
y'all sat here and y'all spent this time
together you know what i mean yeah all
right i appreciate you guys i appreciate
you
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself